[موسيقى]
حبيبي ، أنا رجل عصابات أيضًا
ويحتاج الأمر إلى فك التشابك ، فأنت لا تريد أن
ترقص معي أرقص معي
[موسيقى
] لقد عدت للتو إلى المنزل وقرأت الكثير من
الرسائل التي لم تكن راضية عن
آخر
مشاركة لي على Instagram والتي كانت  فيديو تيك توك
وعادة لا أعتذر عن هذه
الأشياء
ولكن الكثير منكم اعتقد أنها كانت غريبة
وأنا
آسف لم يكن ذلك في نيتي لذلك
اعتقد الكثير منكم أنني كنت أحاول أن أكون
مغرًا مما يعني بوضوح أنني "  لست
ممثلة جيدة جدًا لأنني كنت أحاول
أن أكون قويًا
وليس مثيرًا
[موسيقى]
كانت ناتاشا قد استخدمت للتو هذا المقطع
حيث رأيته على توك القراد
ولذا كنت أحاول أن أقوم بنسختي
الخاصة منه مع الكتاب المقدس
و  تحدث عن الروح القدس
وقوة الروح القدس التي
لا يمكن لأي شيء في الأساس أن يتفوق على الروح القدس
ونعلم فقط أنه من خلال قراءة
الكتاب المقدس
ربما كنت أحاول فقط أن أكون
هادئًا جدًا أو ذا صلة بطريقة كتابية
لم تنجح